Chicago known for Wrigley Field duh
Bears and deep-dish pizza now wants to
be home to Chewbacca r2d2 and everything
else that comes with a George Lucas
Museum it's a win-win for the city of
Chicago Mayor Rahm Emanuel set a target
at 55 million Chicago visitors a year by
2020 with a total of forty eight point
four million last year Lucas's museum
could help close the gap there needs to
be some real destination drivers and of
all the things that I've seen in my
three plus years in this job this is
truly one of those game changers the
proposed Lucas cultural arts museum
would be a 300 million dollar showcase
for Lucas's personal collection of art
and memorabilia featuring names like
Rockwell parish Amidala and Vader a
vision is in place even if the location
isn't quite yet in Chicago a mayoral
task force has just recommended 17 acres
of lakefront property currently home to
the Bears soldiers field parking lots
Chicago would lease this land for one
dollar a bargain for George Lucas but
city officials hope that the force of
the museum will attract visitors and
revenue the star wars empire has already
earned 27 billion dollars and with
another movie in production and two more
planned there's no apparent end to the
interest in the franchise or the man who
started it
San Francisco where star wars was born
federal officials rejected George
Lucas's original proposal to build his
museum in a national park overlooking
the Golden Gate Bridge still local
leaders are hoping home team advantage
can win you think it's a natural tie the
amenities digital media and you know it
is it is lucas's home but ever since his
marriage to Ariel Investments President
mellody hobson Lucas is called Chicago
his second home and Chicago has its
advantages for all the people that this
museum is going to draw I think getting
in and out of Chicago is going to be a
lot easier than getting from one coast
or the other to quote a small but
powerful Jedi impossible to see the
future is